[Music]
in played myself news you made yourself
submitted by straight-to-dvd I want a
movie straight-to-dvd yeah those make a
lot of money I think that's more movies
environmental investment I don't have a
DVD player what is like today's version
of that straight to streaming straight
to streaming straight to Netflix Digital
straight to digital download yeah like
digital gonna straight to iPod iPad or
to one of those weird sites you know
that I thought they are like Hulu
Netflix Vimeo straight to or even even
the weirder one the video on-demand yeah
- you poor woman was surprised to
discover the drawers she purchased three
years ago was actually a different color
this is such an important story guys
what happened is she purchased some
drawers three years ago that she thought
was one color but it's actually a
different I was well it changed colors
over the years it was actually a
different color all along which she just
realized she was kind of blind that
would have been better so this story is
so exciting so I'm pumped so important
so this tell me how she got bamboozled
he was Kaley not Kaley yeah she's 14 35
so she and her husband purchased this
drawer units and her husband got duped -
yeah and their two kids so they all went
to the store got it together and they
thought it was the same color so she
really wanted these particular drawers
and this gray color mm-hmm but this
place only had it in this blue color
oh she was like damn it sucks but you
know what it matches the rest of my
furniture sorta I'm gonna get it anyway
she bought it three years ago then she
recently she was doing some cleaning and
she was like oh you know what I think
it's time to peel off this protective
this protective thing for the drawers
right but she thought it was clear she
thought that her Georgia blue turned out
no her drawers were gray this whole time
oh my god the color that she's always
wanted
this is Caitlyn your husband it's like
this is a troll No are you [ __ ] that
is all about the protective filming blue
Wow shocking how did this make the news
now are we talking about it's because I
think it's like I'm so confused
everyone how [ __ ] dumb they are yeah
this is like something that like my
mom's friend would talk about like like
the restaurant and I'm like that's the
biggest thing that happened in her life
yeah she thought she had these blue
drawers it was two idiots
so she manages family the kids done got
the kid the kids that you can't blame
the kids well kids are just smarter than
the parents my kids don't he don't know
[ __ ] about furniture yeah baby and like
a toddler she was gray the whole time
and it was it was great the whole time
but the reason why she thought they were
blue is because at the furniture store
the display that they had was blue
that's like people in the friend zone
it's like I didn't know you were my
dream guide this whole time they just
have to like peel the like layer off and
they're like oh [ __ ] you were there the
whole house to match that blue and they
peel that I've life [ __ ] this isn't
matching more so it's brand-new now
exactly it so she said she was like dude
it's like brand spanking me sometimes I
refused to peel things off yeah me too
just in case yeah that's what my mom is
to this bag I can't see got me for
Christmas
yeah this part right here that I never
used this thing was blue and since it's
from Tiffany's if that was like a
Tiffany oh yeah beer that you're one of
those yeah it was whatever or like this
lady so then not until like I started
peeling up I was like what the hell and
I peel it off was like oh [ __ ] it wasn't
blue the whole time oh you know what for
my car I didn't realize how many damn
stickers cars gray but I can
I feel like four months straight I kept
finding things to peel off
oh yeah with our watches that we got I
kept peeling [ __ ] off I'm like what
little the little stickies all over
right like on a corner yeah
I never feel off the mirrors a makeup
you know like wouldn't you open it and
they have the little protective thing Oh
cuz I'm like oh I want it to be a mirror
for when I really really need it and so
I just never never little of that oh
really
oh oh what if it's still on it a bunch
of blue mirrors different mirrors make
sure you like this is where all the
stickers are just in case this is a
sticker I think it's for fun it's like a
little scavenger hunt makes those pseudo
like there's a factory that makes this
there's someone that's putting it on
yeah furniture is [ __ ] expand if you
want legit legit furniture I couldn't
believe the first time I moved out of my
parents house and I was like I need some
night IQ Oh one-night stand is $99
that's actually very narrow that's a
good price for one but when you first
move out though you add it all up your
life or like the furniture we had at my
house like my parents house and it's all
solid wood [ __ ] right I'm like man that
shit's tackies bugs waxes cheap and then
I go to Ikea it's like [ __ ] particle
board it's like I would look school bus'
all modern but it's so it's so expensive
and it even that good and then I look at
solid wood [ __ ] and I'm like holy [ __ ]
that's in the thousand yeah but it's
just the one that your parents have look
ugly as [ __ ] because like when you live
with your parents you're like trying to
gauge prices you're like I would pay $20
for that then you go to the real world
that you're like I know so many hours of
work it is the one that [ __ ] me up the
most and it's not furniture we're like
books for college Oh [ __ ] me up my
freshman year cuz I'm like oh okay I'm
gonna need five books I think I could
get it with 200 bucks bucks and one book
was like $400 BAM
got you right there you've been praying
it's called it's a scam it is dude and
you could barely sell it back - yeah
like it's like $75 yes yeah I've always
bought janky furniture up until recently
just because I knew I was never gonna
either consistently yeah yeah but now
that I've moved into a place I'll
probably stay there for next two years I
feel like when you move in with a girl
she always wants to pick new [ __ ] yeah
you know me but I'll tell me it wasn't
even that way it's me it's the other way
around I wanted to buy nice [ __ ] cuz I
gotta look at this [ __ ] all the time and
so for me because I haven't bought real
furniture in a minute it's just been the
cheapest thing at IKEA as long as it
look kind of decent like I don't realize
how heavy real furniture is - like a
coffee table I can't lift it by myself
like I was like what the [ __ ] am i I got
that much weaker and I looked at the way
it was 200 pounds
oh there's [ __ ] coffee tables because
it's like metal and it's just solid wood
but it looks so good yeah yeah of course
is it looks to me like you feel good
about it in your house you're like I'm
an adult like and I'm okay like putting
my feet on it because I'm pretty sure
the structure is gonna stay good defend
me it's not gonna like lean over or
something I hate the ones where it's
like all shaky and you have like a cup
of water and accidentally bumps into it
yeah screws - you know what the best
part about good furniture is it's way
easier to set up because it's not
dissemble - it's like [ __ ] finer
points like IKEA like all the others
should that we assemble it was like 12
screws yeah can you put it together you
put the legs on it yeah that's it yeah
what the [ __ ] man I'm so happy about
that [ __ ] I know but that [ __ ] the
[ __ ] yeah the coffee table was alone
was [ __ ] $450 the [ __ ] where'd you
go shop yeah well I saw it and wait it
was no I got a couple stuff at Wayfarer
I didn't like it West Elm it was
actually fed Bath & Beyond yeah
furniture yeah and beyond so I saw a set
that I really really liked because it
was like super sturdy I said realize how
heavy it was but now I look it I want to
keep it for a very long time so I'm very
happy about tell you have a kid we have
a super dope coffee table
the minute that kid came you turned into
a preschool and that [ __ ] is not pairs
now Oh
oh that's right because that's like the
player and now I love that coffee table
because it's so big one big one we want
a big one for activities and we had
activities for like two or three months
and other things up there well guess
what when [ __ ] Tiger malaika turns to
four years old you could bring that back
down and then he could play on no but
then you got it - you're holding another
- no I'm coming yeah doesn't [ __ ] that
kid dude Oh what if she's all cute and
like I'll girl what if it just looks
like psycho a long hair me my brother
looked exactly a lie I liked when you
were kids
yeah like twins almost mmm well that's
that's the cute that is usually once
older or younger I might like it in the
same thing no I'm like five years older
so he would look like my old pictures
basically oh thank you yeah you keep
looking like them we did that face you
know when I had that face whopping I did
it with like how we are now and me with
my brother's face just looks like my
brother it's my brother what happened to
your [ __ ] grasshopper garble was hot
it was very on a Grande yeah Gary yeah
okay so is Gary and then we found out
you internet Gary was a girl she laid
eggs and then supposedly they only live
for one or two months after that because
that's like their final stage of being a
grasshopper but she lives like five
months after that and then like recently
there was tons of rain and everything I
had an umbrella covering her and she was
like super secure and safe but then we
had this like wind storm like crazy wind
blew the [ __ ] away and we'll the
umbrella that I had covering her knocked
over and it's like this heavy ass piece
on it like it doesn't knock over ever
and like it's a hundred pound base and
yeah it knocked over and the tree that
she was all like got flattened and she
was gone whoa yeah she hasn't been back
what about her baby they are supposed to
nymphs are born and late spring so like
May so that whole thing how you found
them
yeah that's gonna happen to you all over
again possibly mm-hmm
yeah but I was hoping that she'd make it
to see her babies because she laid eggs
on my birthday by the way that's the one
day she laid eggs and that was in early
November November 2nd and she just flew
away like 2 weeks ago so March but do
you know if a guy came in jizan all
those eggs I don't know I don't even
know if they need a guy or if they're
just suffering they don't need juice
they might not I don't know what if she
got just in and then she shot the eggs
out we know nothing about impossible if
she just got used by her brother's did
you see her doggy start getting doggy
style by the grasshopper were you even
looking for it yeah animals are like
hillbillies they [ __ ] each other all day
long I have too many if too many of them
touch each other they turn into a swarm
of locusts and they destroy farmlands oh
[ __ ] yeah
see try software's turned into locusts
yeah maybe it activates a chemical so he
rubbed their hind legs together yeah and
then activates this chemical that
basically turns them into like mr.
Hyde's
and then they actually change colors
into like this yellow color and then
they get aggressive and they just try to
find other grasshoppers to make a swarm
and then they make a swarm of locusts so
they're like a they're like a protest
yeah and that's what happened in like
the Bible we're like all those like
locusts came and ate all the corn or
whatever hmm they destroy crops like all
they had to do was eat the locust
[Music]